mine should be in some things I'm very
German the things Germans place a lot of
emphasis on like precision and
punctuality I learned very quickly if
you want to live here you have to learn
about German qualities video doctor
starts vadhana she decided to live in
Germany in 1972 when he came to Berlin
as a tourist from Srilanka he was 19 at
the time
a family friend adopted him which
allowed him to stay permanently the
girag nurse studied to be a dental
technician then in the early 1990s he
turned his hobby into a profession and
opened his first restaurant in Berlin's
Kreuzberg district it was the first
location in Germany devoted to Sri
Lankan cuisine when I came to Germany I
started to cook for myself
when I invited friends over I'd cook
something nice like a full Sun Bowl a or
dal curry various things and they all
said Wow EJ you can really cook why
don't you open a restaurant in Berlin
we'd all go to it when the trattner
starts Varanasi did open his restaurant
it was considered quite exotic few
people here knew anything about Sri
Lankan cuisine but Berliners are curious
and many of them quickly became regular
customers his idea of using organic
products in the dishes was also well
received so well that he was able to
open a second restaurant the Surya Kunti
in 1997
we're in Sri Lanka see a client in Sri
Lanka is a small island but a lot of
coconuts grow there so we use a lot of
coconut milk in our dishes which makes
them different and we use spices
differently too we use a lot of smoked
and roasted spices that's something
special every dish that we make has its
own typical taste yeah ma I get mugged
in Sri Lanka curry usually means dish
not the spice his korabik harry uses not
only the stem but also the leaves there
are hundreds of different ways to make
curry using vegetables meat or fish
curries are common in Sri Lankan cuisine
[Music]
in this island country in southern Asia
people typically eat with their hands
food is served lukewarm or cold
Oh
Oh
but traditional sri lankan dishes are
usually spicy the spice is used often
have a medicinal effect
[Music]
Oh
rice is one of the staple foodstuffs
it's served with every curry
[Music]
we use these curry leaves or carp India
in every dish every one these curry
leaves serve to detoxify the body they
have a very unusual taste they smell
good and they're also very healthy you
can buy them here in Berlin but only in
specialty stores a lot of hard work went
into making this Surya Conti which means
sunshine
Richard Aetna star Sweden Archie spent a
year and a half renovating the former
pub he tore down walls and decorated the
remaining ones together with an artist
the color yellow predominates
symbolizing both the Sun and curry
ventures from old commuter trains
service seats the restaurant is in
Prenzlauer Berg in the eastern part of
the city it's an area that has undergone
enormous changes since the fall of the
wall in 1989 what was then a
working-class district has become a
trendy part of town not only has the
number of chic cafes and boutiques
increased so have the rents I do damage
compared to when I started here two
decades ago the difference is like night
and day
back then the buildings were completely
rundown and dilapidated now they've all
been modernized restored when spruced up
the neighborhood has changed completely
these are Keith is fully under 7 VT
Ratner starts Vida not she has spent
more of his life in Germany than in Sri
Lanka
the only thing he hasn't got used to is
the German weather hi everyone
Habibi noble avenged enact a blood of
the camera